يوم داما في غزه ونتنياهو يامر الجيش
بالاستعداد للمعركه اجراء اول عمليه
جراحيه في العالم لدماغ جنين داخل رحم امه
الفرنسيه تكشف عن الوكاله الفرنسيه تكشف
عن انتقال ميسي الى الدوري السعودي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
البدايه من قطاع غزه حيث ادى قصف جوي على
مواقع مختلفه في القطاع الى مقتل 13
فلسطينيا بينهم اطفال وقيادهم بحركات
الجهاد الاسلاميه الناطق باسم حركه حماس
قال ان الحركه ستشارك في الرد على الهجوم
الاسرائيلي ماكدا ان عناصرها موجوده في
غرفه العمليات المشتركه التي تقود عمليه
الرد على هذه الجريمه فيما كاد رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو انه اعطى
تعليمات للجيش بالبقاء مستعدا لمعركه
متعدده الجبهات قائلا انه سيعاقب كل من
يحاول المساس بان اسرائيل
من التصعيد في غزه الى تطورات في السودان
حيث يدخل الصراع يومه الرابع والعشرين في
ظل شهود ترمي الى انهاء المعارك والوصول
الى وقف دائما لاطلاق النار مراسل العربيه
افاد مندلاع اشتباكات في ام درمان
والخرطوم وسمع اصوات مضادات في وقت حلقت
فيه طائرات بسماء العاصمه فيما حضر قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان من انتقال الحرب
الى ولايات اخرى في البلاد مضيفا انه يسعى
الى وضع اسس حقيقيه لوقت القتال تشتمل على
الانسحاب من المناطق السكنيه
بعيدا عن عالم السياسه حيث نجح اطباء
امريكيون في اجراء عمليه جراحيه نوعيه
لدماغ جنين في رحم امه لعلاج حاله طبيه
نادره هي الاولى على مستوى العالم
الجراحون استخدموا تقنيه جراحيه لعلاج
التشوه خلقي يعرف باسم تشوه وريد كاليتوس
الذي يسبب قصورا في القلب واعراضا تشبه
السكته الدماغيه بعد الولاده فيما قال
الطبيب المشرف على العمليه ان الطفله ولدت
بعد العمليات بيومين وهي الان في الاسبوع
السادس ولا تتناول اي ادويه ولا تعاني اي
اثار سلبيه على دماغها
في خطوه لاقت تمديدا من البعض اعلن مالك
تويتر ايلون ماسك عن خطه لتطهير حسابات
العصفور الازرق القديمه التي ليس لديها اي
نشاط الملياردير قال في تغريدته اننا
سنطهر الحسابات التي لم يكن لها اي نشاط
خلال السنوات العديده الماضيه لذا من
المحتمل ان تشهد انخفاضا في عدد المتابعين
فيما فات التقارير بان العديد من
المستخدمين اعربوا عن قلقهم من الخطوه
طريحين سؤالا حول ماذا سيحل بحسابات
الاشخاص الذين ماتوا واشاروا الى ان حذف
حسابات احبائهم هو اشبه بازاله شاهد القبر
على حد وصفهم
وفي خبرنا الاخير كشفت وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه ان النجمه الارجنتينيه ليونيل
ميسي سينتقل الى الدوري السعودي الموسم
المقبل دون الاشاره للنادي الذي سيلعب
لهطلع على المفاوضات قال ان صفقه انتقال
ميسي تمت وان العقد استثنائي وضخم وبصدد
انهاء بعض تفاصيل الصغيره فيما نفى والد
ميسي تلك الانباء مؤكدا ان القرار النهائي
بشان مستقبل ابنه سيتخذ عقب نهايه الموسم
الحالي
[موسيقى]